-We are hanging out with
the great Mark Hamill,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's the one and only.
Now, Mark you've played several
iconic characters
over the years.
And we thought we'd put your
knowledge of your own characters
to the test in a new game called
"Know Your Role."
Here we go.
-♪ "Know Your Role ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
I'm going to give you
an obscure fact
about a famous character
you have played,
and you have to tell me
if you think
that statement is true or false.
You ready?
-Oh, it's true or false,
which is much better odds
than multiple choice.
So that's good.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
It's kind of multiple choice.
It's 50/50 multiple --
Yeah, it's two.
Yeah. Alright, here we go.
First up, Luke Skywalker.
He, of course,
is the main character
in the original
"Star Wars" trilogy.
But there might be some things
you don't know about him.
Let's see if you know your role.
In the original draft of
"Return of the Jedi,"
Luke was going to
turn evil at the end
and team up with Darth Vader
to take on the galaxy.
-I pitched that to George,
because I thought that's the way
things were going in "Empire."
I got the gloved hand
and I was dressed all in black.
But, actually, George said, "No.
It's a fairy tale for children.
Luke is --
You know, he's virtuous.
He's the good guy."
So that's false.
-Yes! Wow. Interesting.
Alright, good.
[ Ding ]
I kind of was hoping that.
I was hoping for that.
Luke Skywalker once
crashed into a planet
where he met Kermit the Frog.
[ Both laugh ]
-Well, you know why
that's a question,
is because since Frank Oz was
operating and performing Yoda
and I had done "The Muppet Show"
a month before he started,
we got visits from
Miss Piggy and Kermit
on Dagobah, the swamp planet.
So there's photographs of
us with big stars,
like I say, Miss Piggy.
But, actually, that's not true.
-You're wrong.
[ Buzzer ]
-Huh?
-It actually is true.
You went on "The Muppet Show,"
and the plot was that
you crashed on his planet.
-Oh!
-We have a photo of you
as Luke with Kermit the frog.
-Wow!
-There you go, yeah.
Yeah. How dumb am I?
Because in telling you that
that was a false statement,
I referenced
the very "Muppet Show"
that proved me wrong.
-That made it true.
Exactly. Right.
That's why the game's fun.
-Duh!
-Alright, good.
Alright, here we go.
"The Force Awakens"
almost opened with a scene of
Luke's severed hand
floating in space.
-It was a severed hand
holding a lightsaber,
flying through space,
and when it hit
the stratosphere,
the flesh and the bone
burned off.
And they followed the lightsaber
as it went into the ground.
And I thought -- And I saw --
I read the whole script
and I thought, "Well,
there's great symmetry here,
'cause I'm in the first shot
and I'm in the last shot."
-Yeah, as if to say
your hand counts.
-Nothing in between.
But that is true.
-That is correct.
[ Ding ]
That is true.
That would have been cool.
I love that idea.
Alright, let's switch things up.
You also played the Joker in
"Batman: The Animated Series."
But the Joker has
80 years of backstory.
Let's see how well
you know the Joker.
-Okay.
-In an alternate reality,
the Joker is Batman's mother.
-Wow. You know, that's --
You know, I haven't read
all the material,
but, I mean, in my experience,
my version of the Joker,
I don't remember that
ever being the case.
Maybe they did that somewhere,
and I didn't read it.
But I would say that's false.
[ Buzzer ]
-It is true.
-Oh, no.
-In some alternate reality,
the Joker was --
yeah, was Batman's mother.
-Does it say where and when and
what you're talking about
or just...
-No. No. It has nothing.
It just says nothing else.
-No. Alright.
So no backup, just trust you.
-Yeah, I just --
It says "Google it."
I don't know.
There's a story line
in the comics
where a monkey briefly
becomes the Joker,
and his signature move
is making his opponents
slip on a banana peel.
-[ Laughs ]
Again, that sounds stupid.
Yeah, I'll just say it's true.
-You're wrong. It's false.
[ Buzzer ]
We made that up.
The monkey wasn't the Joker.
But the Joker
could be Batman's mother,
but it's not a monkey.
-I was going to say,
is that any crazier than
him being Batman's mother.
-Let's not be ridiculous.
-Good grief.
It would never be a monkey.
Here we go.
Let's get to Skeletor.
You're playing the
He-Man villain Skeletor
in the new Netflix show
"Masters of the Universe:
Revelation."
Let's see how
you know that role.
Your character, Skeletor, is
often depicted as evil,
but according to
a TV special in 1985,
he actually loves Christmas.
-[ Laughs ]
No, he's the evil
Lord of Destruction.
No, he must hate Christmas.
[ Buzzer ]
-He loves Christmas.
-Oh!
-He loves...
They did a special,
and, apparently, at the end,
he really -- he loved Christmas.
I don't know where --
Again, I don't have any other
facts except that you're wrong.
That's all it says.
-Well, this quiz is going to get
me kicked off the show.
-Never in your life.
You're a legend, bud.
Finally, here we go.
Skeletor is He-Man's
estranged uncle.
-False.
[ Buzzer ]
-It is true.
I didn't know that.
I just found that
out today, Mark.
I found that out today.
It's a weird thing.
You go, "What?!
That can't be real."
Skeletor is He-Man's
estranged uncle.
-And now I'm wishing
you asked these questions of
Mark Wahlberg.
[ Laughter ]
He would have done better.
-No way.
No one better than Mark Hamill.
That's Mark Hamill.
Watch "Masters of the Universe:
Revelation"
on Netflix, July 23rd.